kind of zombie stronger you'll be the
first to die but I like your enthusiasm
you might die yeah thank you for your
sacrifice
hello I'm woody hi I'm Emily
Emma yeah my relatives Emily I'm a VL
but you can call me Abby I'm Jessie
that's it we're the cast of Zambia and
double-tap so please please go see our
movie we're begging you okay so the
here's the question that what he's gonna
ask for us hmm
all right that's a lot of drama what was
it what was it like reuniting as a cast
this is a very good question ten years
later did you pick up right where you
left off it was interesting because when
we left each other ten years ago we were
in the middle of a sentence and I think
it was Jessie you went and that's why I
told him no yeah right when we got and
then we got back yeah yeah that we
weren't talking about some current event
yeah phew because that would have
expired we were on underhooks
yeah I think I think we picked up right
where we left off I think we had a
really great yeah time you know yeah we
did in a new more mature way you'd say
hey delay ha a couple of characters meet
their doppelgangers in the film have
people told you that you have a
doppelganger and have you ever met them
well I have two very similar in many
ways friends Owen Wilson and Matthew
McConaughey okay cuz you guys have
similar Cadence's right yeah well we're
all Texans yeah that makes sense what I
wouldn't say you're Doppel yeah my
brother's reselling that exact right
brothers what who's in it would be
playing that exact yeah I don't really
know that I have won a lot of I mean I
people told me that I look like people
they tell me I look like how they go
present all the time but then I think
Kirsten Dunst I got a lot of communities
that yeah
just like Virgin Suicides Kirsten does
thank you
yeah my sister so um my sister's friend
once told me you look like this guy in
this movie which was me she's like oh
but don't worry you're like a lot
better-looking oh yeah yeah you want to
be better-looking on screen than you are
oh yeah I want to leave it all there you
know leave it up on screen well I I went
to see a show a concert recently and I
someone came up to me and was like hey I
was just wondering if I could get a
picture with you and I was like oh you
know I'm just at this concert it's a
friend of mine is prefers like Alan
Cummings concert is like a hot you know
like any night a night but sorry you
know and he goes all right well fine I
think you're great on Will and Grace
oh no I was Debra Messing he thought I
said yeah I guess then we're missing an
eye oh that's my story for the day and
aside from the character you play who
would you say is your favorite character
in the new film and why I like the guy
who plays my doppelganger right yeah so
in other words it's true that you tend
to gravitate toward people who are more
like you who look like you yeah exactly
in life you mean yeah I guess so yeah
stead of biological think about how many
people they get married and they really
look a lot like their spouse well that's
for breeding purposes right that's what
I was referring to oh I love Zoey
deutsches character Madison I think
she's so funny and Zoe is such a
brilliant actress I mean every all the
new characters are fantastic people and
characters but I really do love Zoe's
character no you're not hey you art no
you're not no you are no you're not no
you're
no you're not tiny big tiny she's
adorable
I love Rosario Dawson's character
because I love rosario Dawson oh okay
well I think someone's gonna have
trouble with that car okay
presidents are Canada Corey bugger
what's your me I would I would say like
Madison I I know
it's really really funny I also I like
Berkeley - yeah I mean I like rabbits
your love in the love of my life I mean
oh can I do
Oh Graceland plays a big part in the
film not entirely true but is there an
iconic location
you still need to visit before the
apocalypse happens this is very I'm from
Arizona and I've never been to the Grand
Canyon
that is weird it's very rude I do I do
need to visit the Grand Canyon oh is
that in Arizona uh-huh
well that's no news cuz I look I kept
looking for it like in Nevada well
that's why you didn't but I did get a
temp a sandwich oh yeah yeah don't worry
they'll tell you how do you know that
hippie was staying at your house how
because he's still there if you invite
Whitney over for a party he'll come to
pm like three hours before the party
starts and he leaves - tastes like yes I
was gonna say the next experience it was
terrible when I finally don't guys
historic for any locations that you need
to see I also haven't been to the Grand
Canyon but yeah grow up like next door
so right yeah
have you been to the top of the Empire
State Building no he isn't bad that's my
great audience
it's your Grand Canyon in the event of a
zombie apocalypse who among you do you
think would be the greatest zombie
warrior we answer this question all the
time no offense Fandango this is a very
common question and we all have a mutual
answer one two three what did he
yeah thank you
there were lots of rules Jessie's
character comes up with him in the film
but in your everyday life is there one
rule you always follow one rule I always
follow I brush my teeth yeah you feel
like you follow be kind every single day
all the time
be kind others and treat them as you
would want to be treated you follow the
golden rule all day every day that is my
key key thing okay this film picks up
ten years after the first Zombieland
what do you think your characters will
be doing ten years from now our
characters surviving yeah yeah kind of
the same probably next raped what is
your perfect road trip vehicle okay well
Tesla Tesla may be sure I mean there
would have to be charging stations right
well this just fits much it would be a
much smarter vehicle in the future as
long as power still going on you can
still you know charge that know rather
than gasoline ever gonna be able to keep
getting that yeah the gas you're not
gonna be able and the last question
perfect timing what are your Road Trip
rules trip rules always have water in
the car that is the worst for news you
guys I always think about hydrated snack
seems you need snacks and also always
know the nearest rest area yeah cuz you
know sometimes like you carry this car
tire cuz that could be real bad right or
just stay on the road trip using good
music maybe music music for your baby if
you just all baby music baby that's
really a music actually just for Jessie
your baby like music like hi wait
[Laughter]
and that's a wrap question feel like we
had more time or mates and 20 thanks
guys
thank you shut up
that sings very 2009 Zombieland
double tap
you